God of War Ragnarok has been a wild and
thoroughly engrossing Journey when
choosing which topic to start with it
had to be the God that I was most
disappointed about not seeing in the
previous game Heimdall as always of
these videos we'll take a look at how
these characters were depicted in
traditional Norse mythology go over some
of the Original Stories and then the
part they played in the game as well as
any major differences there of course
will be Major Spoilers so if you have
yet to finish the game you have been
warned
the first time we see Heimdall is when
atreus is climbing the wall of Asgard
and he appears to be keeping watch from
this interaction and heimdall's snarky
dismissive and condescending tone we can
tell that he is not a pleasant God to be
around and in my opinion easily a
contender for the biggest douchebag of
the series award along with Odin once in
Asgard before meeting with Odin
atreyus's tormented some more by
heimdell with Thor being the unlikely
Savior and voice of reason we see him
now demonstrate his super speed but we
hear from Odin that he can also read
minds and has exceptional skills of
perception he just isn't much of a
people person but what about heimdell in
Norse mythology here Heimdall is the god
responsible for keeping watch for
Invaders and these signs that Ragnarok
is upon as God's doorstep he lives in a
place where he's AI meets the bifrost
known as himmingbjorg the protector of
the bridge in and out of Asgard he has
extremely heightened senses being able
to see and hear things no human nor most
Gods could detect the foreknowledge we
see in the game also exists here being
able to see events just before they
happen this is why he has the galahorn
so he can signal to those in Asgard that
the Invaders have arrived just before it
actually happens ironically in the game
the horn is used to unite all the Realms
against Asgard and some uncert to begin
the final battle of Ragnarok heimdal is
also referred to as the whitest of gods
as well as being born from nine sea
maidens so the circumstances surrounding
his birth are slightly weird he also has
gold teeth which we do see in the game
and his dislike for atreus or or Loki is
also mirrored at the final battle of
Ragnarok Heimdall and Loki kill each
other so not exactly the best of friends
back to the game Heimdall makes it known
that he knows atreus plans to betray
Odin and throughout the game it's no
secret that he despises atreus or Loki
and looks forward to killing him heimdow
is described as the most devoted
follower and believer of Odin hearing of
the prophecy that states atreus will be
killed by heimdell Kratos has no choice
but to kill Heimdall first although this
is no easy task luckily Brock however
has a plan for Kratos using the magical
ring drop near which has the ability to
duplicate itself they combine the ring
to a weapon and create a magical spear
that can duplicate itself hoping that
all of these duplication Shenanigans can
overwhelm heimdell's senses when and
Kratos finally encounters Heimdall we
get the boss fight that's been building
for a while as the Fight Continues we
see that heindel can slow down time
briefly as well as having the ability of
conjuration when Kratos cuts off his arm
he spawns himself a new spectral arm
Brock's plan is a success as Kratos is
able to defeat heimdell and despite the
prophecy he chooses to spare him
accepting that Kratos who he deems as
lesser is willing to take pity and spare
him is too much for Heimdall after some
insults and the inability to acknowledge
that he is beaten he gives Kratos no
choice but to kill him even calling him
a monster just before he dies which is
ironic coming from someone who just
threatened to kill a man's child
anyway thus ends the story of Heimdall